gop councilman joe borelli joe great to
have you here look
we know these guys don't like each other
we know they have this thing going on
they're like the two guys in the muppets
the old guys the old men who don't like
each other but the act
is getting is getting stale at this
point because people's lives are on the
line
why couldn't they come together just
this one time for a somewhat coherent
kovid strategy
but but this is what it's like living in
new york city you you have these two
guys they're like playing dueling banjos
but one has a trombone and the other one
has a harpsichord
i mean they they can't seem to even get
on the same conference call
so that they're even announcing one
thing if you read the new york post
yesterday morning you would have saw
newspaper articles highlighting the the
struggle of small business owners who
were just devastated that bill de blasio
was shutting down their business again
if you open today's paper you're going
to see those same business owners saying
wow
i don't have to shut down after all i
mean this is no way to run
a city let alone one that is in the
midst of a serious pandemic
i'm glad businesses aren't shutting down
but the consistency you see out of both
mayor de blasio and governor cuomo is
really
upsetting and should be troubling to new
yorkers especially
when you think about the inconsistency
in cuomo's entire state of new york
we have areas of this state that have
higher positivity rates than new york
city
and despite governor cuomo saying he
wouldn't send his kids to those schools
there are still schools open in the
hudson valley orange county
rockland county even with those high
positivity rates it makes no sense
it makes no sense it's confusing to not
only people in new york but the
people outside of new york who are
looking at the greatest city in the
world as we say and wondering what's
going on
let's just do a quick review cuomo just
wants to shut down certain schools de
blasio does want certain non-essential
businesses
to close but take a look at these
unemployment numbers from
august they are not good unemployment in
the city just the city alone
16 what is your message to de blasio on
what he is doing
to small businesses and the people that
they employ
look ty i had a long conversation with
mayor de blasio the other day and
i really don't think he's hearing from
the the sector of new york city
that is struggling to reopen i think
he's somewhat in a bubble of of people
who are
just fearful and want things to stay
shut down he's not really hearing from
the parents who need schools to be open
from the business owners that need
business to be open and i i just i don't
know how much more we can try to get the
message to him
that the only way new york city is ever
going to recover
is when we have children going to school
and learning and when we have
businesses operating as as close to
normal as possible
joe i hear it in your voice it is a
broken record that doesn't seem to be
able to get fixed
joe borelli we appreciate you being here
and raising these issues
once more jillian over to you thanks
doug